hey guys were here with d-trix what's up
bad for just a little bit of an awkward
situation I'm so excited that you're
here
thank you for inviting me I know what
we've been trying to do this for a while
and I yeah I suck at life and but now I
meet you but we're here it's so exciting
how did you get d-trix as a nickname
okay my best friend in high school saved
me cuz I want with tricky D and I feel
like my best friend's name was Mike
Martin and he was like maybe we should
go like d-trix cuz I'm not gonna think
of you like and we were like legit
street dancers it's like trying to be a
bad boy cereal mascot no kids if you
could talk to your belly button
what would the conversation be like dogs
in the surrounding areas first and I'm
like y'all need to chill figure this out
figure this out so it's not just the
belly button the surrounding point belly
button you're great I would like to see
you again so tell your homies so I chill
out like it's just Taco Bell you eat a
lot of fast food and all the challenges
but do you like fast food like in real
life I think my favorite restaurant of
all time is 7/11 not a restaurant is
pleasing so what is it you eat there the
hot dogs no no I don't know I'm not too
crazy on that's like super cheat day
yeah term super cheap year but for me
it's like these sandwiches yeah the Box
challenge it like this all-star sandwich
yeah it's enticing right yeah it's like
it's like you got the ham and then like
these little bacon bits with a little
bit of Turkey so makes you feel better
about yourself right right but then they
got you know like the lettuce and tomato
and you have two days eat this thing
they make it into a game yeah it's a
game now and I'm like my mine and I look
at the expiration days I'm like cool
I've two days on this one or have one
day on this I
of 7-eleven they were in my life at one
point then they weren't in my life and
then moving to Los Angeles they came
back into my life it was like oh my god
this is just like really connecting me
to my white trash nests that I've been
so far away from I love their coffee
situation yeah I will pass on a
Starbucks every day just to go to
7-eleven and get like blueberry flavored
coffee because wine is great 24 hours a
day open in the invite if this one's
like okay there's too many cars in this
parking lot I'll go to one across the
street for being on it it's like one of
the tough things about me the honesty
factor is like that's a good and great
thing but I love I love women okay
I love women and and if there's no woman
than porn comes that's a good thing yeah
Wow what could it mean have no idea we
gotta look that up what does it mean I'm
Sylvester Stallone is looking at you and
your dreams Wow you gotta get him in a
video